I don't know what the heck is going on,
I don't know. Normally, I would get
bored of it sooner and quit.
I'm not afraid of my parents I
'm not afraid of this monster
I'm afraid of me
Remember what's so scary that your body rejects it Image of
brushing away your
master's words
Telling your
wishes to
Yumiya You're a liar, so you're still a liar
[Music]
I
'll live on the stairs
[Music]
[Applause] Or did
you lose your
mind?  I
saw my parents at the metropolitan government, they're all right
I'm in the middle of the harvest festival I have to
go home
to everyone So after
all
it's a chance to prove
that even humans can stand next to everyone
In this festival that decides the strongest devil
[music] I
'll definitely win
[music]